cinéma avec la sortie sur les écrans
mercredi prochain d'un film américain
entre adultes consentants
avec julia roberts natalie portman et du
glo une histoire de couple et de
trahison amoureuse qui a emballé les
critiques outre-atlantique qui croule
sous les nominations aux golden globes
qui seront décernés ce soir à los
angeles pascal deschamps juge visage
comme l'apparition cgt parfaite et alice
épouse dan qui va tomber amoureux d'anna
qui elle vient d'épouser lary qui finira
par séduire à nice un scénario tout en
méandres comme un fleuve et comme pour
le fleuve le lie à son importance il y a
dans cette histoire toute la matière qui
fait le piquant le tragique de la vie
amoureuse entre adultes consentants des
rencontres des coups de foudre des
serments la vie à la mort et des
trahisons
j'ai aimé le fait qu'il aborde de
manière très honnête la palette sur des
relations amoureuses
eh oui si humain avec humour un champion
sans avoir sur les jce et les
personnages sont complexes et vivent des
situations complexes
on se rend compte à quel point les êtres
humains se comporte de manière bizarre
pourquoi vous les faites perdre son
temps vous êtes implacable
vous êtes perfide à celui c'est pas
perdre son temps elle est absolument
adorable et totalement équitable et vous
ne voulez surtout pas qu'un autre la
pelote qui nourrissent les hommes il
sensé son décor est quand même super
bien sûr en surface il est question ça
que je relations sexuelles derrière ça
il y a le problème de la compassion
qu'on doit avoir pour les otages et tim
henman
est ce que tu m'as jamais un chassé
croisé amoureux plein de rebondissements
tangente aucun personnage ne sortira
indemne tu mens car dans les jeux de
l'amour comme dans ceux de hasard 100%
des perdants auront tenté leur chance